I am a light in the bottom of the ocean
[Music]
buried in the silence of years
I am the lights of the spirits
[Music]
I often think of the middle passage as
the origin story for Africans in the
Americas
during that transatlantic slave trade
period we know there were tens of
thousands of ships that traverse the
Atlantic we estimate that there are 12.5
million people who were taken from
Africa the intent was to make as much
money or profit as possible often as
many as 600 people would be chained
together and put in the bottom of a
cargo holds of a ship people suffered
from starvation and illness there were
sharks that followed the ships because
of blood that was in the water from
people they threw overboard when you're
trying to engage in this subject of
slavery there are no easy conversations
the work is in the attempt to to tell
the truth to confront to help people
reckon with this history
Africans live in various countries in
Africa don't think of themselves as
black that's an outside observation
before people boarded those ships they
belong to this ethnic group or this
tribe that's when this thing called
black was born
where do we put our sorrow where do we
reconcile our history and where do we
reconnect with our heritage all of us
look for a touchstone generations later
there are people who are descended from
the continent and they can go back and
touch these historic sites even
underwater I was living in DC and the
Museum of african-american history and
culture that opened and at the very
bottom of it
it has artifacts from a ship they were
part of the larger story that I was
getting and then I make it to the second
floor there was this picture and I go to
read the plaque about it and it says
it's this group called diving with a
purpose and this is a part of the slave
rexis project which is a larger
collaboration of partners who are
dedicated to finding these slave ships
around the world when I see the name of
this guide can Stewart so I used to go
diving we would get on the boat and the
folks on the boat wouldn't buddy up with
me my assumption is is because I was
black it happened several times and I
didn't know really what to do then I
found out about dr. Jones and the rest
is history a lot of people consider me
to be the Dean of african-american
divers and I learned to dive in a
military my first official died was 1951
dr. Jones is truly one of the greatest
black men I have ever met when I came
back from the military there were people
who had heard about diving whether they
didn't know how to do it one by one
people started contacting me so I said
well let's form a club
these people were intent on telling
their own story and I thought the human
journey of Africans in the Americas has
not been told from this lens anywhere
now first some to archaeologists came in
to give a talk on a henrietta maria
slave ship
well once we saw the shackles it really
upset the people we decide we were going
to put a plaque down on on the Henrietta
Marie
now I've made over 6000 dives that was
one of the most memorable dives I had
because it was like diving on a grave
site
you do feel like you're visiting the
souls of your ancestors when you're dead
and it's just difficult to explain the
feeling sorrow anger disgust and you
feel sort of feeling helplessness we
said you know we need to go out and find
in slay ships
[Music]
then we got lucky
and I can Stewart met Brenda Lazar dog
who was the archaeologist at Key
Biscayne State Park
she needed diamonds we had diver she
said I will train you guys to do this
work if you were to help me map this
ship she says you know I'm the lone
diver here in the park and you know as a
diver
we can't dive alone earning 10 were
these visionaries for this program after
a few years you know under her
instruction tutelage she said okay now
it's your turn I'm gonna sit back a
little bit
she said that we're not to keep this
program to ourselves you have to train
other people there's a rise in the
interest and study of the African
Diaspora of our past but there's not
real space made for people who actually
look like us this lens of people who are
descendent from Africa is crucially
important because these are stories that
have not been told when presented with
this opportunity to expand my impact
create pathways for students it seems
like a no-brainer it's like okay so how
are we gonna get these kids in the water
[Music]
make sure that you close to them with
your buddy we have an hour trip to the
dive site you will be getting a briefing
and before you get into the water I'll
be recording your time in so what we're
doing out here on this very beautiful
day we have four because some underwater
archaeology advocates what we teach here
is the basic principles of how to
document a shipwreck how to do
measurements underwater basic mapping
techniques we are training them to be
able to go into a wrecked ship wreck
landscape and began the initial process
of gathering data
so we do maritime archaeology which
enabled us to uncover the sau Jose
the Sal josée is a slave ship that
starts in Lisbon travels to Mozambique
picks up captive Africans to sell them
into enslavement in Brazil the ship goes
down just off the coast of South Africa
what we're doing here is helping to tell
a story on a human scale a story about a
ship and the five hundred and twelve
people who were enslaved aboard that
ship and the search in all its levels
for and around the ship creates deep
connections
I do recall very as think to blame when
I first encountered the wreckage of the
South Susanna being in the water for me
it can become very very meditative and
quiet and beautiful but when that Beauty
sort of encapsulated a slave ship wreck
you know there's another sort of feeling
you get and I just remember seeing that
that wretched stand and so I approached
the wood and I'm resound and grabbed and
tested and whatever you want to call it
I could feel the vibration the energy
and the pain and the suffering and the
horror it's like I kind of closed my
eyes and I could audibly hear the the
agony and the scream if I close my eyes
and all I could think was to say inside
my head we never forgot about you we
came looking for you and we found you
when we encounter these labor excites we
like to go back to those people that
particularly ethnic group and tell them
that we found their ancestors
in Mozambique Island we met a gentleman
he is a member of the Makua tribe and he
gave to us a Cowrie shell in case basket
inside that basket he had put soil and
that soil came from the site that was
the last footfall of people on the
African continent before being ordered
to ships
he asked us to take the soil and to
bring it as close as possible to the
rack that was an opportunity for healing
and that was an opportunity that was
symbolic because it connects the
Americas
it connects South Africa it connects
Mozambique and it connects it to the now
and to the past
[Music]
now what happens when you take that
sense of adventure and you pair it with
social responsibility
that's when sparks fly we're training
young people in diving they're becoming
certified divers and at the heart of
that is heritage stewardship I love this
idea of young black mind stepping into
the sea and claiming it this has been a
very successful field school so we thank
you very much for all that you will
continue to do as advocates of the ocean
and cultural heritage management I think
it was a great year did some outstanding
work with that said we're gonna
recognize our new advocates what we can
do is gather knowledge and pass it on so
then stop it one generation two people
but it keeps on going
what would it mean to tell those stories
that we don't get in our history books
and I think us asking questions of this
history the ways that we do bringing
these stories to life
it makes them real these are the kind of
stories that we can't let die that story
of resilience of holding on to humanity
that story of refusing to be dehumanized
is such an important story for this
world today
I think the healing part of this work is
the community that comes out of
humanizing these experiences I didn't
expect it to feel this way it feels
[Music]
we know that we're speaking for millions
of people who are here we can't see them
all but we know that all of us every
ancestor we've ever had is alive and
present within us today we are their
blood their flesh their bone and every
generation yet to come is alive and
present in us today
the Atlantic is one of the most
turbulent of all the oceans
[Music]
and I've been thinking about the people
who've never been honored they've never
even been acknowledged their stories are
just lost
[Music]
perhaps there's something spiritual
that's happening in these oceans
there's a need to lay the ancestors to
rest
[Music]
and the search in fact never has
[Music]
the search for ourselves never adds
so this whole question of identity and
culture particularly for people of
african-american descent is a huge
struggle who do we call ourselves
are we Negro are we black or african
americans who are we
I am a black girl from Atlanta but I'm
also a nerd really in the sci-fi and
when yoga enthusiast like there are all
these parts of me that make up Who I am
but that don't get seen because people
just see the blackness and that's how I
get to find
my wish my dream for other black folks
around the world is to be able to exist
inside of their wholeness and to have
people see that and recognize that
that's the work that is happening here
I am the sea light
[Music]
I have walked the waters
[Music]
and I have been in the memories lost
only with the spark of the hope that
someday some diver would look at the
artifacts that are the traces left of
the people and asked the questions that
have not been asked
what people must have come in those
ships
[Music]
[Music]